this message is for bird me and Theo
come from the same cloth looks like I'm
coming from God but how do you drink so
much and stop for sober October how do
you do that I can't even imagine just
stop and drinking like that without any
program or anything like that how do you
do it Burt Gang Gang wait how do you
yeah how do you do that you just shut it
down you me you know do you know ramping
up until October you like okay September
I'm gonna drink as much I got a I got a
we're gonna have this last night is
gonna be a big party you have a party
the night before no yeah no actually
usually I'll quit drinking a couple days
before just kind of Pratt no just
because like I go I don't want to ramp
up and be hungover October first where
I'm like oh I'd rather have that [ __ ]
day here so that if I need a glass of
wine to go to bed like if I'm like you
know I'm gonna have a glass of wine so
like I'll kind of taper it off and then
and then I just stop I've done it both
ways I've did it this last year I got
[ __ ] wasted September 30th or
whatever and then turned it off the year
before I kind of tapered off a little
bit the year before that I think I the I
think I didn't drink because the rule is
you can't you got to stop drinking at
midnight right so you can't you can't
build up to midnight and then go I'm
done that's not gonna happen
yeah so like I always taper it off a tad
bit but uh yeah I don't know man I have
a weird thing in my head it's it's very
punitive I'm very punitive I'm a little
obsessive-compulsive so like like what
I'm not drinking right now I'm not gonna
drink for the next probably I mean I may
I never met anybody drinking here no no
no no I meant I meant this I'm not
drinking right now this time of my life
oh I see you're saying it's so we got a
lot of work to do too right now yeah and
I got plenty of [ __ ] free time I'm
like dude last thing I'm gonna do is
[ __ ] a bunch of free time up with booze
yeah it's like when you go on vacation
my biggest mistake when I was younger is
I go on vacation and get [ __ ] wasted
little time come home and be like more
tired from the vacation life yeah I went
on vacation one time to Hawaii my wife's
like no booze I did it and I had a
[ __ ] blast up early jogging
women snorkeling oh look the greatest
vacation so I lost to you oh dude
LeAnn lumps good out here oh when I'm
out there I feel like I'm supposed to be
out there me too
you know we did in Fiji we kind of
floated the reef or they drop you off
and you just kind of cruise with the
reef oh it's leaking pretty cool Fiji
was [ __ ] awesome it was really great
RMS a Fiji Bali Fiji is great too oh wow
what the BG as well Fiji is amazing but
Bali's [ __ ] legit I don't know I wish
I could tell you I've talked dr. drew
about it why I get to this place where I
shut it down and then I don't and then
I'll tell you right now man if I if I
don't drink for this whole time we're
off or whatever time we're off I'll have
a really hard time starting again do you
feel like you have to drink cause of
your show and cuz your act I think I
think people would be really I think
people would probably look at me
different I think people look at my show
is I got a reason to tap out and have a
good time yeah and I think they I think
let's go celebrate
I'm also the guy that like when I go to
a party like with parents
I'm the guy that gives everyone a
license to get a little loaded yeah and
I don't you can never tell when I'm
wasted I mean I can but you normally
people can't so so it I feel like they
go on the lips get wetter I noticed that
yeah yeah it's okay that but um but yeah
I don't know how I I don't know I wish I
knew and I've talked to dr. drew about
um I don't think so
he does up I think you're gonna have
health problems if you continue the way
you do it yeah so that's where I like
turning good evening good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one